couple things here ESG Dei has the FBI
been bullied by the esgdi stuff or not
yet are they sitting there saying hey we
need to make sure the people were hiring
a third of them are from a
underrepresented community whether
they're part of the lgbtq disabled black
you know I was hoping to have Middle
Eastern in there they don't have it but
Native Americans some things like that
is there anything like that happening
within the FBI it's rampant right is it
really I know you said about the pride
flag that was in there but what do you
mean full-fledged unpack that for us uh
intern in my office uh she came in one
day and was a he with blue hair and we
all just had to move on this is somebody
who needed a security clearance to work
in the facility she needed a security
clearance to go from a shituhi no just
to work in the FBI facility that's why I
can't I couldn't be an FBI agent anymore
they suspended my security clearance for
looking at the employee handbook
improperly
and this being came in and and obviously
had some some mental issues yeah and
that was something that we had to accept
and just move on from the trans woman
you're saying yes and now is that a gun
in your pocket or are you just oh okay
sorry you're not bad the academy now has
issues where there are females that are
claiming that they're male but they
still want to use the female standards
for the physical fitness test so they're
having to
deal with that speed bump how about from
the top I mean that stuff I can see
happening because it's a little you know
weird today the market is a little weird
today
how about from the top are you guys
hearing stuff from the top you know the
headquarters Ray people from the top
saying here's what we need to do moving
forward when it comes down to recruiting
guidelines Etc et cetera is that
happening yeah that's that's a full
initiative that we need to do diversity
hiring they've reduced the uh standards
for for some matters of hiring because
they want to increase their pool of
minority applicants and then and if you
just want to go on a strict gender basis
FBI is majority male it's law
enforcement however they want equal
representation amongst the management
class to be male and female so there's a
disproportionate amount of female
representation within the leadership
structure because it just isn't there
aren't a lot of females that join the
FBI to begin with so a lot of those
females are elevated very quickly
because they have to fill those slots 50
50 or close to 50 50. how much of this
is trickled down from the stories that
used to come down from J Edgar Hoover
everything you know the store is the
this is the FBI building
cross-dressing high heels we don't talk
about that oh now this is can't talk
about really let's strict their voting
it's wow you joking are you you're
assuming you're joking right most people
don't most people in the FBI don't know
the history of the FBI yeah
it's a government it's a government
agency that you might as well be working
for HUD yeah for most people it is a
government job based on our company what
does that mean you don't know the
history of the FBI I don't know about
Hoover or cointelp
it's it's you guys know more about the
FBI than most FBI employees correct
how's that possible
willful ignorance willful ignorance and
and I think a lot of people that join I
mean look at full disclosure I saw a
Point Break and looking they look like
an awesome job the FBI agent but I also
crazy
I wanted to be Fox Mulder yeah wow
so that was the inspiration yeah there's
Jared Hoover yeah but I think a lot of
people it's it's a very high paying job
with a lot of esteem attached to it yeah
and there's a great opportunity to be
underworked and overpaid you know if
you're even as an agent you only have to
do one investigative activity per case
every 90 days that's very unfortunate
they don't teach the history of the FBI
to you know it's it's like what we see
running rampant with kids they don't
teach everything about the
Constitutional Declaration of the
independence everything that how
government works you see these men on
the street interviews can you name the
three branches of the government they're
like uh I don't know uh so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign